for the last um several weeks i i've
really made it a point
not to talk much about q anon
and uh what it is and at this point i
think i have to
because it is actually starting to
become
um something that is of interest to
my audience and and unfortunately maybe
even relevant in some
broader sense so to talk to us about it
today we're going to be speaking with
alex kaplan
who's a senior researcher at media
matters focuses on social media
misinformation
disinformation and online extremism uh
great to have you on alex
thanks for having me on so i mean okay i
guess to start with
it clearly this q anon is substantial
enough
that an organization like media matters
is paying attention you're tracking it
you're researching it it how do we
establish
how much of a thing this is yeah
so um i would say until recently it was
hard to get a sense
of exact numbers for how many supporters
uh there were of curuminon there were
definitely signs that it was significant
um in the last uh few weeks
we've gotten some reporting that has
finally given a sense maybe more
concrete numbers there was a report
uh from nbc news that uh
according to a facebook review of
queuing on facebook groups it found
i believe at least three million members
of q and on facebook groups so i mean
there could be overlap between
groups some of the groups but i think
that gives a sense that
there is a significant amount of people
that
are sympathetic subscribe to cert
traffic in this conspiracy theory online
if someone does not know what the
conspiracy theory is
what are the kind of highlighted bullet
points of it
yeah so uh it's an extremist conspiracy
theory that started in late 2017
um on a message board site called
4chan which is known for hosting
anonymous white nationalist trolls
essentially
its premise is that there is this
anonymous entity
called calling itself q claiming to have
q security clearance in the government
uh claiming to have this inside scoop on
this secret plot that uh president trump
is involved in that actually originally
involved special counsel robert mueller
uh to take down the deep state uh
his perceived enemies uh this pedophile
network this global cabal
of like pedophiles that includes
democrats um
and that they'll be basically walked
into thrown in the guantanamo like
court-martialed
um that that's kind of the premise of it
and it moved to
another even more extremist site uh
message board site called a-chan which
is
got shut down because it was tied to
white nationalist shooters or alleged by
nationalist shooters and is relaunched
as a site called acon
so that's where it is now and that's
basically its premise some elements of
this remind me of a uh blacklist episode
i think james spader was uh involved in
the direction of that particular episode
but but in all seriousness
so this is this is a pro-trump ideology
that that frames trump as a sort of
savior or
white knight for lack of a better term
in the in the global context
yes uh it is a pro-trump conspiracy
theory
that uh claims that he is going to uh
what they call like the storm this event
where like all the enemies or
all their perceived enemies are going to
be like mass arrested and
court-martialed
um and yeah i mean the conspiracy theory
supporters traffic in pro-trump
narratives pro-trump content
um the heart of the conspiracy theory as
you said is that uh
trump is the savior the central figure
of this secret plot
so this is not just online
and this is maybe why we're now taking
it more seriously which is that there
are
you'll tell me the number but certainly
more than 10 candidates
for congress at the national level who
are
at least to some degree affiliated with
q anon
yeah so um over the course of my
tracking
uh i have come across at least uh
78 current or former congressional
candidates
78 that have at some
level expressed some kind of support for
the conspiracy theory so that include it
does include former candidates but
candidates that all
ran at some point in 2020 for congress
so
because it's very easy to run in some
kind of
nominal sense it in terms of right now
in terms of on the ballot in november
what would the number be
so at least uh 20 of those 78
have secured a spot on the ballot in
november
um of those 20 19 are republicans and
one is an independent
um it is possible that number will go up
because there are some primaries left to
go
and are these individuals well let's
work backwards i mean when donald trump
in a press briefing
i think it was last week but it might
have actually been two weeks ago at this
point
it was probably two weeks ago during the
dnc was asked about this
he kind of played dumb but also said it
sounds like they're saying i'm doing
good things and of course that's a
really good way to get trump to say
at least not negative things about you
to what degree has this administration
commented beyond that one event on cue
so yeah as you said trump made a comment
uh or
remarks making saying positive things
about the conspiracy theory
and its supporters um it you know
leading up to this
trump himself has amplified q anon
promoting accounts by my account more
than 200 times
um and there were other people in
trump's
orbit that have winked at amplified q
and on content
um his social media advisor dan scavino
has linked up the conspiracy theory a
few months ago i found
uh he posted or posted an image on
facebook
uh a photo that had a cue in it and i
was able to trace it back to a q anon
supporter that had posted on his
facebook page
um his son one of his sons eric trump
posted a q a on graphic on instagram
which she then
took down without any explanation it was
a clear q anon graphic
uh his former social media national
security advisor michael flynn
uh in july posted a video of himself
taking an oath
uh supporting queuing on an oath that
cue the entity behind q anon had posted
uh i believe it was a couple of weeks
before um and
and some of his uh campaign staff have
gone on a q and on
youtube channel so uh there were
connections
uh before this we're going to go to a
brief break on the podcast but we'll
continue our conversation with the media
matters alex kaplan you'll find the full
conversation on on our youtube channel
so has q anon inspired acts of real
world violence that we can pinpoint in
other words
how how serious of a real world threat
are some of the people associated
yeah so uh q and on its supporters have
been
tied to multiple acts of violence at
this point there have been
multiple acts of multiple murders uh by
cueing on supporters
there have been uh multiple attempted
kidnappings by q
on supporters there's been other one
there's been threats
there was one woman a q a supporter uh
who went to new york to i believe she
said she was threatening to take out joe
biden
um there was another q anon supporter
who uh
or a person who expressed support for
queuing on who had threatened to kill
the governor of michigan and its
attorney general
um there are others but those are just
some but there's multiple others
what are the actual murders that have
taken place um
the two that i know of there was a q9
supporter who killed a mob boss
in new york um and i believe
the other one was a man who killed i
think it was his brother with a sword
uh i believe he also affiliated himself
with the proud boys
besides being on supporter we can't
necessarily say that it was
under the direction or ideology of q
anon
that those individual incidents took
place but what we can at least say
is that there are people involved who
are not
um who are certainly
willing to do violence whatever banner
it is sort of happening under
yeah there was um another incident i
believe
recently a man was in a high-speed chase
with his family inside and there was vid
he think he was recording himself during
it
and he said during it q help me um
so i mean that that was a case i know of
where q anon was directly invoked during
the incident
so at a big picture level i mean how do
how do we deal with this we so clearly
it's gotten enough attention where it
made sense to
to talk to you about what this is and
the extent to which it pervades social
media and it pervades
of ballot boxes elections in the
upcoming november election but like
what how do you determine whether it
makes sense to ignore something or
actively refute it or to put a spotlight
on it i mean
how do you guys make that determination
so
there's a term that is used regarding
whether to amplify
conspiracy theories misinformation or
disinformation or to deal with
robotic grapple with it uh it's called
like a tipping point
um or it's basically how i follow it you
know
are we at a point where the risks of not
dealing with it
outweigh um the concerns of amplifying
and giving it oxygen
um with q and on we are we're well
beyond it we we're
extremely beyond it at this point i mean
really we we saw
q on supporters having signs at trump
rallies since 2018
at least um this this thing is well
beyond the concerns of uh
oh you know there's worries about giving
oxygen we're well beyond that
it needs to be dealt with and discussed
at this point that's a
similar strategy i mean to give you an
example years ago
i interviewed the white nationalist
richard spencer
and my calculation at the time was
this guy is getting a lot of attention
serious interviews in corporate media
that are not really coming in equipped
to really challenge him on his views
it seems as though it meets a certain
threshold where it would be worth
bringing him on i don't think i would do
it now because i think that that
threshold
he's sort of faded into obscurity in a
certain sense so that
you're sort of making a calculation on
that basis
yes um yeah i mean there were signs that
this thing was growing
for for the last couple of years i mean
i i've
i've been following the conspiracy
theory myself since
not long after it started um at least
early 2018
and i'd heard about it soon after it
started in 2017.
um but i've been personally keeping
track of it in a while because i mean
it's been having an offline footprint as
we if we as we've discussed
uh it's been tied to multiple acts of
violence uh we didn't
i mean the fbi released a memo warning
is a potential domestic terror threat or
presented as such
and one of the other reasons i focused
on it so much is that
its supporters and i've lost count of
how many times have repeatedly played
major roles spreading misinformation on
social media
it just seems like every time i track or
most of the times i'm tracking
uh a campaign or just the path or food
chain of cert
misinformation that are circulated on
these platf tech platforms
a q a on account or q accounts are
playing a significant role in spreading
it is this the type of thing that goes
away if trump wins
and their candidates don't get elected
in november or
do you sense that this is something that
could have life beyond november
regardless
yeah i don't think this it's hard to say
for sure but i don't get the sense that
this just goes away
um i mean q and on supporters
ha i mean the thing with q anon is that
its supporters
have been able to make everything
connect to the conspiracy theory or
prove the conspiracy
theory somehow i mean yeah i mean it's
like
it's like the conspiracy theory that
includes all the conspiracy theories i
mean even kobe bryant's death to give
you an example was incorporated the
conspiracy theory by some
just to give an idea of how like
everything's included here so i don't
think
trump loses losing winning or uh either
way
means this just goes away maybe it takes
on a new form
it's hard to say for sure but there's
just been so much time for this to grow
and develop on the tech platforms
i don't think this just goes away you
mentioned that there are 20 candidates
on the ballot in november that are in
some way
sort of sympathetic to or under the
umbrella of q anon
how many have a shot in your estimation
so
i'm relying on the political analysts
here but uh i think the sense is that
two of those have
a more significant shot but than the
others um
one of them is george's margin retailer
green
right um she has gotten a significant
amount of attention recently um
she is likely to be elected to congress
uh she um was a pretty clear q and
supporter uh 2017 2018 she talked
extensively about it
uh you could find things on social media
where she would tweet the q a slogan
where we go one we go all
uh she would post things on facebook
like oh great posts from q today
uh she called cue a patriot on fit on
video
uh she wrote blogs about q anon she
echoed content from q a
from q posts um she's since tried to
distinguish
herself a little bit from it but what
she said was kind of
dubious uh about why she distances
herself supposedly and how
um the other candidate is colorado's
lauren bobert
um she uh got attention because she went
on a
youtube or show hosted by a q a on
supporter and was asked about it and she
said positive things about it saying
like she hope is real
and that it brings people together uh
she has tried distancing herself i would
say more than
even green has she's claimed that
killing out is fake news since then
yeah but the thing is that she's also
gone on another q
and on youtube channel and uh there's
evidence that we found that she had a
youtube
account that subscribed to q and on
accounts or just keeping on channels
so the other q a on ties um so those are
the two
that probably have the biggest shot
we're going to keep following it as
as as you will of course we've been
speaking with alex kaplan who's a senior
researcher at media matters
alex i really appreciate your time today
yeah absolutely